foreign
hey
just dies
[Music]
it's nice
what what
[Music]
a jacket
foreign
problem out here you better bail
where are you here
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
slowly
hold on
what are you doing shotgun
throw on the ground watch that ramp
I ain't got no way off that roof
turn off your engine
trust me
he's on the road
he's flying on rooftops
foreign
[Applause]
ing suspect vehicle anyway
foreign
Stay With Me
[Music]
well there he is
thank you
just hold on
now there's a Batman
[Music]
oh you want to play come on
come on
he missed
[Applause]
you can't stop here we're like
ducks
come on
[Applause]
come on come on I want you to do it I
want you to do it hit me
foreign
could you please just give me a minute
if we're gonna play games
I'm gonna need a cup of coffee
the good cop bad cop routine
not exactly
[Music]
beautiful
ah
never start with the head the victim
gets all fuzzy you can't feel the neck
see
you wanted me here I am
and you didn't disappoint
he let five people die
then you let them take your place
even to a guy like me that's cold
where's Dent those mouthfuls want you
gone so they can get back to the way
things were
but I know the truth there's no going
back you've changed things
forever and why do you want to kill me
I don't want to kill you what would I do
without you go back to ripping off mob
dealers no no
no no you
you a complete me you're garbage you
guilt
don't talk like one of them you're not
even if you'd like to be
to them you're just a freak
like me
they need you right now
when they don't
they'll cast you out like a leper see
they're morals they're code
it's a bad joke
who dropped at the first sign of trouble
they're only as good as the world allows
them to be
I'll show you when the chips are down
these uh these civilized people they'll
eat each other
see I'm not a monster
I'm just ahead of the curve
I just did what I do best
I took your little plan I turned it on
itself
look what I did to this city with a few
Drums of gas and a couple of bullets
hmm
can you you know what I noticed nobody
panics when things go according to plan
even if the plan is horrifying if
tomorrow I tell the press that like a
gang banger will get shot
or a truckload of soldiers will be
blowing up
nobody panics
because it's all part of the plan but
when I say the one little old mayor will
die
well then everyone loses their minds
introduce a little Anarchy
upset the established order and
everything becomes chaos
I'm an agent of chaos
oh when you know the thing about chaos
[Music]
you live
you die
now we're talking
[Music]
Jesus costumes victory has defeated you
thank you
hahaha
yes
the opticality and deception powerful
agents to the uninstead but we are
initiated
ugly Bruce members of The League of
Shadows
and you
and you feed us
yes you are asking hurricane but again
the Psychopaths
the League of Shadows I'm here to
fulfill Raza Ghul's destiny
foreign
you fight like a younger man there's
nothing held back
mistake
oh you think darkness is your ally
are you merely adopted the dark
I was born in it
molded by it
I didn't see the light until I was
already a man but then it was nothing to
me but Brighton
Shadows betray you because they belong
to me
I will show you where I have made my
home whilst preparing to bring Justice
then I will break you
your precious Armory gratefully accepted
we will need it
oh yes I was wondering what would be
first
your spirit
all your money
thank you
[Music]
are you
cover the doors
we're never giving to an ordinary
surgeon where it is
actually
tell me where the trigger is
then
you have my permission to die